déjà mon Farès comment ça va toi
ça va un peu ça va un peu tu es content
d'être avec nous
tranquille ça te fait du bien bon ça
c'est bien
aujourd'hui pour l'instant ça rafaré ce
n'est pas retourné à l'école
pour l'instant il est pas retourné à
l'école vous êtes obligé de lui faire
cours à la maison c'est ça donc c'est
vous qui lui donnez des cours oui j'ai
récupéré les
cours de l'école et c'est à la maison
alors est-ce que vous avez eu un retour
de l'établissement scolaire depuis votre
passage dans l'émission vous nous avez
dit que parce que avant votre passage
dans l'émission vous n'aviez eu aucun
contact avec le réunion le jeudi mais il
m'avertendu avec la police devant le
collège d'accord et sinon non rien de
plus et vous avez dit quoi que c'était
sur le départ quoi après le il me
demande et vu que c'est moi qui voulais
plus les mettre à l'école il me
demandait un courrier pourquoi je dis
scolarise moi c'est moi qui décide de
scolariser mon fils exactement alors
est-ce que vous avez eu un retour de
l'établissement scolaire depuis votre
passage dans l'émission non ok aucun
donc vous êtes passé dans l'émission
plus rien
le directeur vous a contacté
ils ont rien dit parce que certains
professeurs et membres de la direction
du collège font courir la rumeur que
Farès sera un menteur qui serait tombé
en se prenant les pieds dans ses lacets
et que c'est un moment serait simplement
en recherche de buzz c'est ça donc c'est
ça l'histoire
alors c'est ce qu'on vous a dit parce
que ça c'est hyper important pour noter
les spectateurs c'est ça qui vous est
venu à vos oreilles on m'a dit vous êtes
à la recherche de buzz donc j'ai
beaucoup de parents qui me contactent en
me disant moi je suis quelqu'un je suis
pas des réseaux j'ai pas d'Instagram
j'ai rien du tout j'ai fait une page
pour mon fils mais je suis pas la
recherche du tout de buzz et ils ont dit
que mon fils était un menteur qu'il n'y
avait pas de harcèlement scolaire dans
l'établissement et qu'il avait chuté
tout seul dans ses lacets qui a dit ça
alors ça s'est passé en cours de
récréation les professeurs le directeur
il y a même une professeur de français
je dirais pas le nom qui se déplace même
jusqu'au lycée pour voir ses anciens
élèves pour qu'ils fassent passer ça sur
les réseaux
d'accord alors
est-ce qu'ils ont été punis les élèves
qui auraient poussé votre fils
et eux on leur a demandé leur version
eux je sais pas les harceleurs je sais
pas s'ils ont été harcelés mais il y a
eu du monde qui a été convoqué ils ont
eu beaucoup d'auditions
qu'ils auraient identifié le chef du
groupe et un autre élève et après le
reste je sais pas
un peu plus tôt dans l'après-midi
aujourd'hui vous avez eu un rendez-vous
au commissariat avec c'est ça que vous
allez nous raconter quel commissariat
commissariat de Carcassonne d'accord
c'est la première fois que vous y alliez
non on a été pour le dépôt de plainte
d'accord pour le dépôt de plainte
comment s'est passé le dépôt de plainte
déjà parce que je voudrais qu'on
revienne dessus parce que vous allez
voir ce que va nous raconter ça c'est
complètement fou vous y allez vous
raconter comment comment ils vous prenne
ça alors le défaut de plein de j'y suis
allé on a voulu déposer plainte contre
l'établissement et contre les enfants
ils nous ont pris que la plainte contre
les harceleurs d'accord donc c'est à
dire ils vous ont dit non ils ont pris
que les harceleurs donc ils ont voulu
non ils ont pas voulu prendre quelles
plantes pour l'établissement contre
l'établissement ah oui ça ils ont pas
voulu ils ont pourquoi je sais pas et
jusqu'à que son papa il s'est énervé
mais c'est à ce moment là que ils ont
bougé un petit peu et ils sont venus ils
ont ramené l'appareil photo et ils ont
fait leur acquisition chez le médecin
légiste donc l'établissement vous n'avez
pas pu porter plainte contre
l'établissement non
mais c'est quoi le
la raison je sais pas du tout c'est les
gars oui j'ai une faille il considère
sans doute que peut-être il y a une
responsabilité indirecte en tant que
personne morale éventuellement mais ils
ont pas voulu cibler l'établissement
comme étant responsable directement des
actes de harcèlement ça se conteste mais
je pense que c'est la version qu'ils ont
voulu tenir je dis pas que c'est la
bonne mais ils ont voulu tenir cette
ligne je pense alors
là aujourd'hui vous êtes retourné au
commissariat Carcassonne c'est vous vous
avez été convoqué c'est vous qui avez
été oui on avait rendez-vous de la 14h30
rendez-vous avec le commissariat
pourquoi c'était quoi la raison à la
base pour une audition d'accord une
audition concernant donc concernant
l'affaire de de Faris vous avez vu la
même personne non c'était une autre
personne là c'était une inspectrice
c'est pas celle qui a pris le dépôt de
plainte d'accord donc vous arrivez vous
dit quoi l'inspectrice alors elle a
commencé à prendre mes disposition déjà
elle m'a dit que on avait raté des
rendez-vous c'est vrai ça non
que vous arrivez vous dit vous avez raté
des rendez-vous
que c'était autre audition vous lui
racontez toute l'histoire
dans les toilettes oui tout tout
d'accord elle a pris votre déposition et
arriver à un moment elle m'a dit oui
hier vous aviez rendez-vous avec un
médecin
je vous ai envoyé des messages et vous
avez raté le rendez-vous c'est vrai ça
alors je vais sortir mon téléphone je
lui ai dit les paroles s'envolent mais
les écrits restent montrez-moi votre
téléphone et le message n'était pas
envoyé sur mon numéro donc je lui ai dit
comment moi je peux être au courant elle
m'a dit oui vous préférez envoyer votre
fichier TPMP
que
justice soit faite elle m'a dit s'il
n'est pas sur place
l'affaire ne va pas avancer donc vous
préférez aller chez Cyril Hanouna voilà
il est mieux ici
qu'à l'école se fait harceler et pousser
dans les escaliers voilà que il faut
qu'il faut qu'elle fasse surtout son son
travail donc qu'est-ce que vous lui avez
dit alors je me suis énervé parce
qu'elle m'a dit que elle avait eu
l'audition de tous les adultes du
collège d'accord donc tous les
professionnels les enseignants oui les
surveillants surveillants et qu'est-ce
qui vous qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit ils
ont dit que quand fares c'est est tombé
les surveillants étaient là et que tout
s'y dise que Farès quand il s'est relevé
donc il serait relevé tout seul donc je
sais pas comment et qu'il aurait dit je
suis tombé tout seul
voilà
c'est n'importe quoi ça
m'a poussé même les gens de ma classe
ils étaient au courant ils ont tous de
la scène et ensuite les surveillants
après ils disent ah oui Nani nanana oui
il est tombé tout seul alors comment
relever on m'a allumé jusqu'à la vie
scolaire
alors donc là l'inspectrice vous dit ça
elle vous lit les dépositions non elle
m'a dit voilà j'ai reçu les adultes et
elle m'a dit voilà tous disent que Farès
quand il s'est relevé dit que vous êtes
qu'il est tombé tout seul donc là je me
suis emportée donc là vous êtes en train
de dire que mon fils est un menteur si
vous pouvez mettre ma parole à moi en
doute mais celle de mon fils ne
permettrai personne de la mettre en
route donc elle a commencé à s'emporter
et elle m'a parlé du plateau encore une
fois je lui ai dit mais en quoi il vous
dérange TPMP
alors je me suis énervé et je lui dis
bon on verra vous regardez la télé ce
soir vous verrez vous avez bien fait je
pense que ça va encore plus les embêter
et elle m'a dit je m'en fous si vous
voulez bien savoir voilà elle m'a dit je
m'en fous de Cyril Hanouna
c'est quoi son nom
mais je peux vous le faire passer
donc je suis sortie en pleurant
on essaie d'aider Farès vous essayez de
faire la lumière sur votre sur le drame
qui est arrivé à votre fils parce que on
en rigole nous maintenant on rigole avec
ça mais c'est vraiment un drame et c'est
vrai que derrière on voit qu'il y a on a
l'impression que c'est un complot contre
l'avocat de la contacter pour déposer
des plaintes donc c'est moi de bâtiments
je peux vous dire que lui il va pas les
lâcher et elle m'a dit qu'il n'avait pas
le droit que c'était à moi de poser des
plaintes mais au commissariat de
Carcassonne qu'il fallait pas passer par
le procureur donc là vous êtes vous êtes
dit quoi alors avec l'inspectrice à la
fin comment c'est fini à la fin je suis
parti d'accord et vous a dit quoi elle
va faire elle va faire quoi on a je suis
parti en hurlant en disant que nous on
était des victimes
mon fils n'a jamais inventé ça je
laisserai personne personne dire ça
cette semaine vous avez également été
reçu par le maire oui de Carcassonne
c'est ça lui il vous a il vous a
contacté que suite au passage de TPMP où
il a été au courant de l'histoire j'ai
essayé de l'appeler avant il m'avait pas
répondu et après il a été au courant par
rapport à l'émission et j'avais
rendez-vous hier ça s'est très bien
passé d'accord qu'est-ce qui vous a dit
le maire il m'a dit qu'il avait fait une
enquête avant que je vienne je vais
essayer de d'appeler le directeur
qui lui a gentiment renvoyé la
secrétaire et qui lui a dit de passer
par l'Académie
au maire Homère
et depuis jeudi dernier cherche à jouer
de l'Académie ils n'ont pas pris au
téléphone et ils n'ont pas rappelé c'est
incroyable
parce que quand une fois que vous avez
été voir la police
du comportement de l'inspectrice c'est
ça ah oui oui et le maire m'a dit qu'il
m'a porté tout son soutien d'accord et
qu'il essaierai lui de son côté à son
niveau de faire des choses
et que de son côté après le collège
c'est l'Académie mais qu'il était
vraiment vraiment
je sais que vous étiez très très pénible
à la sortie du commissariat
vous étiez en pleurs c'est ça j'ai eu
votre je sais que voilà et je peux vous
dire que c'était sincère les pleurs de
Sarah parce que j'étais avec mes équipes
au téléphone et je vous ai entendu
appeler c'est vrai que vous étiez dans
un état lamentable
donc là l'affaire est au point mort
donc là pareil ça peut pas retourner à
l'école il y a pas de solution c'est
incroyable donc il y a pas de solution
la police vous dit non mais on s'en fout
aller sur TPMP c'est ça parce que c'est
une classe ici que c'est une école non
mais la police vous dit allez chez TPMP
le directeur dit au maire non il faut
appeler il faut appeler l'Académie et
pour et tout tout au collège comment il
s'appelle Jules Verne Jules Verne donc
la Carcassonne à Carcassonne
mais il faudrait peut-être qu'ils nous
qui se remanie se manifeste le collège
Jules Verne à Carcassonne c'est bien
qu'on le répète voilà donc Farès qui est
un garçon vraiment pour qui maintenant
déjà que je les mets avant et maintenant
on a eu une relation vraiment très
particulière tous les deux je vraiment
c'est c'est mon petit chouchou et c'est
vrai que c'est un garçon qui a un amour
donc voilà avec nous depuis le début de
la semaine c'est un amour voilà et c'est
vrai que nous on a énormément de peine
que ça bouge pas pour lui et une fois de
plus on le voit encore dans ce pays le
monde marche à l'envers pays marche à
l'envers on marche sur la tête ici je
vous le dis c'est à dire que c'est lui
qui est harcelé qui doit pas c'est lui
qui est poussé dans les escaliers et
c'est lui qui doit partir c'est lui qui
se retrouve dans la merde non mais et je
vous dis on est on est dans un monde où
là vraiment rien de tourneront c'est un
truc de fou Gilles est-ce que vous avez
des enfants ce qui est incroyable
honnêtement c'est l'inertie de
l'établissement du chef d'établissement
mais aussi de l'Académie le seul moyen
qu'à trouver l'Académie pour communiquer
c'était leur communiquer de presse du 30
mars qu'on avait passé ici avec une
phrase surréaliste une procédure interne
est en cours pour objectiver la
situation c'est au milieu ça ne veut
rien dire c'est à dire que il minimise
depuis le début pour eux il n'y a rien
il faut le dire ils font tout pour
étouffer l'affaire alors pour dire qu'il
se passe rien d'une personne qui est
qui me dit ayant de nombreux témoignages
de parents dans diverses affaires la
maman de Farès doit s'attendre qu'on lui
mette des bâtons dans les roues quand on
commence à s'attaquer à l'éducation
nationale exactement reçoit des
intimidations et des menaces exactement
et vous vous souvenez que dans le
communiqué Cyril on avait relevé ce
passage incroyable où il reprochait le
comportement violent du père on en avait
parlé c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont essayé de
retourner l'affaire et c'est ce que vous
disiez ils vont essayer à la limite de
vous culpabiliser en disant vous avez
menti c'est incroyable je pense
honnêtement qu'au stade où s'en est il
faut que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a agisse réagissent prennent
conscience de cette affaire il y a des
millions d'affaires
et aider
et au moins qui mène une enquête sur
cette affaire parce que cette affaire je
vous le dis elle est incroyable et je
peux pas croire que Farès est tout
inventé depuis le début et je vous dis
c'est ça m'a l'air quand même très très
suspect cette histoire et même que le
maire ne puisse pas intervenir auprès de
l'établissement c'est quoi là-bas
je dis bravo votre mari est-ce que moi
j'ai la même chose je peux vous dire que
ça va ça ça serait mal terminé oui
Michel on en est où là tu as des news
toi du directeur de quelqu'un
ok
[Musique]
c'est bien bien particulier c'est quel
regard cet enfant de 12 ans va avoir sur
la justice à 12 ans voilà ce qu'on lui
montre à la fois d'éducation nationale
de la police et de la justice après pour
ce qui est de l'enquête
c'est extrêmement simple cette enquête
il y a une école il y a par définition
plein de d'enfants plein de de prof etc
il y a trois faits distinctes et à la
fois où vous l'avez surpris surpris son
agresseur en train de l'étrangler une
autre fois où c'est votre mari ou
ex-mari je ne sais pas peu importe qui
va le secourir dans les toilettes de
l'établissement et la troisième fois où
on récupère vous récupérez votre fils
KO par terre dans une mare de sang et à
chaque fois il y a des témoins donc
l'enquête l'enquête elle est pas
compliquée à faire il suffit si on dit
par exemple que vous avez menti
sur l'appel de votre fils quand il est
dans les toilettes par les fadettes du
téléphone de votre fils et la
géolocalisation du téléphone de votre
mari on va retrouver cet appel donc non
mais déjà déjà je vais tenir Michelin
qui s'est passé au commissariat tout à
l'heure c'est une administration ce qui
s'est passé à l'établissement c'est
inadmissible et que le maire on espère
qu'il est sincère voilà et qui fait
vraiment tout ce qui peut en tout cas si
il nous écoute si nous regarde il
faudrait qu'il fasse vite quelque chose
avec son autorité de merde et qui voilà
interviennent vite d'ailleurs il est de
bonne volonté j'espère que il est
toujours et qu'il a pas et c'est pas
laissé aussi en grainer par les
différents messages qu'on peut entendre
voilà et qui disent tout et n'importe
quoi franchement il faut une
intervention du ministre parce que
pareil
des scolarisé pendant des semaines et
des semaines aujourd'hui donc c'était
incroyable ce qui vous détaillé
franchement je vous dis on est tous
choqué par cette histoire c'est
incroyable c'est vous vous retrouvez
donc sans rien donc là c'est point mort
je sais pas si donc la demande vous
savez pas ce que vous allez faire
la semaine prochaine il va faire quoi il
faut que ce soit réglé avant la fin de
la semaine et le problème que j'ai
maintenant c'est que il va retourner à
l'école là-bas
ça va être compliqué pour lui sinon
surtout les enfants les enfants ils ont
fait passer les messages ma fille la
grande aussi elle a reçu des messages en
disant vous êtes des menteurs vous
cherchez le buzz donc
vous vivez un cauchemar ah oui sur le
côté famille et tout on a plus de vie
bon ça va ça je suis sûr que ça va
s'arranger et que et on va trouver une
issue à cette affaire vous avez pas
envie de changer de parce que c'est ça
qui est fou c'est qu'on va en venir à
changer de lycée ou de collège c'est
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
les solutions
qui s'appelle la France de tout tout
marche à l'envers phare et surtout quand
tu restes avec nous pour l'instant mon
chéri et on est très heureux de t'avoir
on t'aime fort et on va trouver des
solutions et on va continuer à creuser
on va continuer à appeler le collège et
on va envoyer même des des gens là-bas
je vous le dis et on va les on va
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait des réponses et
jusqu'à ce qu'on puisse savoir parce
qu'on va montrer aux Français ce qui se
passe là-bas je vous dis on en parlera
tous les jours tant qu'on n'aurait pas
trouvé une solution pour phare et son en
parlera tous les jours dans l'émission
et je peux vous dire que ça va buzzer et
que ça va faire boule de neige donc je
peux vous dire voir rappeler le nom du
collège Jules Verne Jules Verne à
Carcassonne le collège Jules Verne à
Carcassonne voilà donc il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose et qu'on arrive à en
parler tous les soirs pour qu'il bouge
et pour qu'il trouve une solution pour
faire exprès on va pas rester des
scolarisés 107 ans